hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter the today
we'll be discussing five of the darkest
Harry Potter theories out there let's
get started Voldemort wanted to
completely destroy Harry it's a
wellknown fact for those of you who have
read or seen the goet of fire that
Voldemort's intentions throughout the
entire plotline of this installment is
to capture Harry at the end of the third
task of the tri wizard tournament use
his blood to reincarnate his own form
and then kill him but what if his plan
was even darker and more Sinister than
all that is it not possible that the
dark lord wanted to completely destroy
Harry in every aspect possible this
Theory suggests that Voldemort's plan
went beyond killing Harry and leaving
him for dead for after his resurrection
the dark lord very easily could have
dismembered Harry and taken a part of
his body to create a polyu potion upon
using the potion to take on Harry's
appearance imagine that he returned
turned to Hogwarts and went on to wreak
havoc within the castle and destroy the
reputation of the boy who lived
disguised as Harry Voldemort could have
murdered other students and teachers
stolen Priceless and Powerful magical
artifacts retrieved his hwrs that
resided there and then fled leaving
death and destruction in his wake the
responsibility of which would have all
fallen on Harry Death Eaters are
actually cannibals as the followers of
the Dark Lord Death Eaters were an
organization of pure BL supremacists who
believed in their right to rule over
Muggles and eradicate halfblood and
muggleborn witches and wizards by the
end of the Harry Potter series it's no
secret that in addition to his
supremacist and dictatorship views
Voldemort's primary goal in life was to
become immortal and so the belief of
many in The Wizarding World is that his
followers got their name due to the idea
that the dark lord wished to Vanquish
death or to put more plainly to eat
death but I'm not entirely sold on that
being the full story I think the
following Theory does much to explain
the name of alem's followers in a way
that completely matches up with what we
know about the dark lord and his army of
evil witches and wizards they were
cannibals simply put imagine that in
order to become a death heater a witch
or wizard would need to eat another
human to officially pledge themselves to
Voldemort the kiss can turn people into
Dementors the ghoul likee magical beings
known visiting worldwide as the
Dementors are some of the darkest
creatur pictures introduced throughout
the Harry Potter series from what we
know about them they feed themselves on
the souls of humans and wizards alike
and become energized by taking any and
all feelings of Happiness from those
around them Dementors are also the
guards of the Wizarding prison asaman
and in extreme circumstances will
perform an irreversible act on witches
and wizards who have been condemned for
their unspeakable crimes an act known as
the dement's kiss or simply the kiss the
effects of the kiss result in the person
or victim becoming somewhat of a shell
of their former self a husk of a human
with the dementor who performed the kiss
having sucked out their soul leaving
their body to function without any real
sentience however imagine if the kiss
did more than remove one's Soul what if
the dementus kiss was just the initial
phase of turning a human into a dementa
thems this theory is based on the idea
that the dementus dark magic extends
past the point of Simply chilling the
air and sucking all the warmth and
happiness from their environment to the
point that it could also breed its dark
magic within a soulless human vessel
filling it with their Mists of Despair
there's also the fact that Dementors do
not breed at least not like humans which
begs the question how do more Dementors
come into being the only explanation we
have currently is the rather vague they
grow like fungi where there is Decay
through Mists of Despair but if the kiss
could turn people into Dementors that
would provide a much more substantial
answer to this question a the which
seems to be alluded to in the prisoner
of aaban when Professor Lupin explains
the following to Harry Dementors are
among the foulest creatures that walk
this Earth they infest the darkest
filthiest places they glory in Decay and
despair they drain Peace Hope and
happiness out of their air around them
even Muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
dementa and every good feeling every
happy memory will be sucked out of you
if it can the dementa will feed on you
long enough to reduce you to something
like itself soulless and evil you'll be
left with nothing but the worst
experiences of your life not to mention
that this Theory would explain how
Dementors were originally born since all
that is known is that they come from the
darkness of the Mansion believed to have
been the home of an incredibly Evil
wizard a cisus in the 1400s a home which
eventually became the prison of aaban
many speculate that it was a krisus dark
magical experiments and acts of torture
that contributed to the dementus
creation so it's rather plausible to
think that it was through aisus dark
magic that dementus first manifested in
witches and wizards that he was
torturing and experimenting on resulting
in the victims becoming devoid of a soul
and transformed beyond recognition
continuing to create more dementes
within aaban undetected by The Wizarding
World would then be relatively easy for
the dementes to do since they are the
ones responsible for burying the dead at
the prison just imagine if they never
actually buried anyone the atmology of
Avada kadavra of the three unforgivable
curses the killing curse is by far the
darkest with the effects of this spell
snuffing out the life of any living
thing it comes into contact with
producing a stream of green light the
incantation for this curse is aada
cadavra which is rooted in Aramaic a
language most closely related to Hebrew
syak and Phoenician and translates in
English to let the thing be destroyed of
course you've likely noticed just how
similar the incantation of the killing
curse is to the common magician saying
of Abracadabra which brings us to the
theory at hand that the similarities
between avadaakadavra and Abracadabra
are no accident and instead signify
long-standing violence between the
Wizarding World and Muggles we know for
certain that the killing curse has been
around since at least
1717 when NADA gavra was classified as
an unforgivable curse and made illegal
so imagine that prior to this law being
instated that many witches and wizards
in protecting themselves their families
and their communities or in believing
themselves to be superior beings used
this curse on Muggles throughout the
Middle Ages in the areas in which
Aramaic was spoken during this time it's
possible that some Muggles may have
witnessed the usage of this curse and
Come Away with Tales of people with
magical ability saying avadaakadavra
which may have eventually evolved into
Abracadabra what's more as this is the
one well-known incantation that survived
Muckle culture throughout the centuries
it's fairly clear that the predominant
interaction action between the Wizarding
World and the human one was quite
violent indeed Harry actually dies from
the killing curse near the end of the
Deathly Hallows Harry bravely chooses to
meet his death at the hands of Voldemort
in order to allow his allies friends and
loved ones a Fighting Chance at
defeating the dark lord and after a
brief stint in what appears to be limbo
parading around King's cross Harry
decides to go back to the world of the
living with the killing curse only
having destroyed the bit of Voldemort's
soul that resided in inside of him but
what if everything that happens after
Harry meets a dead Dumbledore in King's
cross is a continuation of his version
of the afterlife imagine that he never
actually came back to life and in
reality he did in fact die what happens
after his brief chat in limbo is just
what he hopes would have happened back
in the real world his final defeat of
Voldemort fulfilling his Destiny as the
hero he was always said to be creating
peace and eventually marrying jinny and
having children that he named after
loved ones but what about the rest of
the battle of Hogwarts you may be asking
I believe that very well could have been
the test he was given to get into the
Afterlife to show that he was worthy of
peace and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
what are your darkest Harry Potter
theories please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content on my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to
live